♪ ♪ ♪
- Qui dit balade en bateau,
dit consommation d'essence.
- C'est sûr que ça fait mal
au coeur.
essent d'augmenter,
la facture est salée.
ROBERT BLACKBURN
- Un petit moteur comme ça
de 260 forces, ça 70 $
de l'heure à faire marcher.
- Robert va absorber le coût.
Peut-être qu'un jour,
il n'aur
(bruit moteur)
... grâce au développement
du moteur électrique.
Vision Marine Technologie est
le seul fabricant de moteur
hors-bord à haute puissance
100 % électrique, au Québec.
Vision Marine Technologies
- L'autonomie est pratiqueme
la même qu'un réservoir
d'essence de 95 litres. Donc on
peut parler de 200 $ aujourd'hui
- Un moteur moins bruyant,
sans gaz d'échappement, sans
rejet d'n-là,
on l'a poussé jusqu'à 32 mille
à l'heure, près de 50 km heure.
On entend qu'il y  qui
bat l'eau, mais la performance
est beaucoup plus élevée qu'und,
mais un désavantage : le prix.
nt pour le moteur
électrique, de 180 forces,
ou chevaux vapeur, il faut
débourser 100 000
batteries incluses.
Le moteur à essence
d'une force simila
coûte entre 22 à 25 000 $,sans .
Patrick est distributeur de
bateau électrique. Selon lui,
l'industrie est actuellement
était l'auto électrique
il y a 10 ans.
PATRICK HARDY,
président BCI Marine
- L'offr- L'offr- L'offr- L'offt
toujours limitée, bien qu'on
sent que les grands fabricants
se structurent pour une offre.
Mais, on voit aussi la naissance
de plusieurs nouveaux joueurs,
comme on en a vu un peu dans
l'électrique dans le monde
des véhicules, des voitures.
- Parce que le potentiel est là.
Selon l'Association nationale
des fabricants de produits
marins, 8,6 millions
d'embarcation de plaisance sont
lation au Canada. Mais,
seulement une infime partie de
ces bateaux sont électriques.
SEAN BERRY, président, Asso.
canadienne bateaux électriques
- Alors pour moi, la conversion
de petits bateaux ça serait une
affaire simple qui aiderait
tout le monde.
- Mais encore faut-il pouvoirlen
sécuritaire. Le propriétaire
de la marina de Boucherville
s'y prépare.JEANNOT JEANNOT JEAe
de la Marina de Boucherville
- Moi je me suis laissé dire
que d'ici cinq ans, il va
falloir que je refasse toute mon
électricité. Quand il va y avoir
des bateaux électriques,
il va falloir grossir l'entrée
électrique. Avoir des sorties
électriques pour tous les
bateaux électriques, ça va
coûter encore X 100 000 $.
- Le flou persiste quant
à l'aide financière accessible
aux entreprises nautiques
pour l'installation de bornes
électriques. Quant aux
subventions des particuliers,
elles sont inexistantes.
Contrairement à la voiture
électrique.
- Que ça soit un... un auto,
un véhicule sur roue, ou dans
l'eau, ou un quatre par quatre
qui est dans le bouve
que ça devrait être les mêmes...
le même programme disponible
pour tout le monde.
ceux qui veulent
convertir leur bateau.
- Ce que moi j'espère voir,
c'est que nos diffiersiersiersis
gouvernementaux nous donnent
un coup de pouce dans
l'industrie. Que l'offre
des chargeurs soit là et on sait
que ça, ça va faire venir le
propriétaire avec son moteur
d électrique avec son
bateau électrique et encourager
e le concessionnaire
de tenir en inventaire et faire
la promotion de ces produits-là.
- Protéger nos cou
tout en conservant le plaisir
de naviguer. Des plaisanciers
comme Claude seraient prêts
à faire le saut.
CLAUDE CHAMBERLAND
- Moi personnellement,
en tant que particulier,
oui j'envisage sortir
une moto-marine électrique.
Je sais qu'ils en ont sorti une,
je pense sérieusement
à l'acheter. Je trouve
que c'cologique.
- S'il y avait des subventions
comme avec les voitures?
- Ah, ça serait sans hésiter.
On irait vers ça, là. Oui, oui.
- Il aura fallu de nombreuses
années à la voiture électrique
pour s'imposer au grand public.
L'industrie nautique rêveansiti.
Ici Marie-Josée Paquette-Comeau
Radio-Canada, Mon